priyanka chopra finally addresses the
scrutiny surrounding dropping the name
jonas from her instagram page it's
obviously been a whirlwind the 39 year
old actress married 29 year old singer
nick jonas in december 2018. in a new
interview with vanity fair the quantico
star discusses the random monday in
november when chopra reverted back to
simply her first and last name on
instagram the move triggered speculation
from fans with theories that their
marriage was in trouble priyanka tells
the mag about her experience with social
media saying quote it's a very
vulnerable feeling actually that if i
post a picture everything that's behind
me in that picture is going to be zoomed
in on and people are going to speculate
it's just a professional hazard because
of the noise of our social media because
of the prevalence that it is in our
lives i think it seems a lot larger than
it is i think that we give it a lot more
credence in real life and i don't think
it needs that it didn't take long to
debunk the marriage rumors when she left
a flirty comment on hubby nick's workout
videos she wrote on instagram quote damn
i just died in your arms followed by a
couple of heart emojis she liked it the
baywatch star is no stranger to public
scrutiny priyanka along with fellow
judges julianne huff and usher was on
the receiving end of criticism for her
role in the competition series the
activist the tv show came under fire for
its format of having activists compete
against each other to spotlight their
causes the matrix resurrections actress
opens up to the mag about how the
situation made her sad saying quote it's
really tragic when something like that
happens because that is never the
intention priyanka also tells the outlet
she's excited about what's to come
saying kids are quote a big part of our
desire for the future back in january
2021 priyanka opened up to et's rachel
smith about wanting kids i read recently
you said you wanted to have a cricket
sized family what does nick think about
that does he want maybe a chess team
instead or maybe a basketball team i
mean cricket that's what like 11 players
come on now free yeah that was a
statement i made many years ago what i
was trying to say was don't hold on to
statements that i made like
10 years ago um i don't know you know
i'll take whatever i can get when it
comes to make a night well hopefully
it'll be soon because we need some more
joe grow babies out there honey and they
they're going to be talented and
beautiful i can tell you well stop with
the pressure
[Music]
you